today we'll be explaining all founding
titans an attack on titan there are some
very interesting titans to cover and we
will cover all of them starting with the
girl who brought the era of the titans
into the world you meer frets ymir was
the first person to obtain the powers of
the titans she was the first ever
founding titan therefore she was named
yamir the founder she has a very sad and
interesting past and to better
understand her powers we will have to go
through her story first around 2000
years ago ymir's village was attacked
and enslaved by the aldians who also
murdered her parents one night ymir
opened the gate to a pen allowing for
some pigs to escape later the ldn ruler
carl fritz questioned the slaves on the
culprit the slaves pointed to ymir who
was released only to be hunted down for
sport wounded and exhausted ymir found
an unusually large tree with a chasm at
its base seeking shelter she stepped
inside and fell down into a pool of
liquid there a mysterious spine-like
creature fused with her and turned her
into the first titan with her newfound
power ymir returned to serve frets and
used her titan to cultivate land build
bridges and amass wealth for the aldians
under his command she also destroyed the
armies of eldian's rival marley to
reward ymir for her service fritz took
her as his concubine and not long after
they had three children maria rose and
sheena during this time ymir grew to
genuinely love and care for friends
despite his behavior and attitude
towards her 13 years after acquiring the
power of the titans ymir died while
thwarting an assassination attempt on
frets but then found herself in a
mysterious barren land king fritz then
forced his daughters to eat their
mother's remains in an attempt to
preserve the power of the titans he
commanded his daughters to continuously
reproduce to have their children eat
their spines upon their deaths and
perpetuate this ritual from child to
child so that ymir's blood would not die
out and eldea could rule the world
forever with its titans yamir's power
was divided into nine titans and she
continued to serve her descendants
building them titans whenever they
invoke the power of the titans but how
powerful was emir actually well ymir was
the very first titan and the only one to
ever possess the complete power of the
titans all who come after her merely
possessed fragments of her power her
titan body was immense even by titan
standards using her immense strength she
could effortlessly wipe out marley's
forces it is said that nobody can
surpass ymir and that because emir died
13 years after awakening her powers no
one with the titan powers is allowed to
live beyond that this phenomenon is
known as the curse of ymir after yumir's
death her spirit lived on in the worlds
where the coordinate resides she is
responsible for all titan
transformations throughout history
whenever the power of the titans is
invoked she builds the titan bodies out
of the otherworldly sand she is also
responsible for regeneration and
re-sculpted zeke's body after he was
blown up it takes him here a very long
time to create these bodies zeke says it
took her years to build him a single
human body but because the world she
lives in transcends time the process was
almost an instant in the physical world
according to zeke ymir can create
anything even chains that represent the
vow of renouncing war ymir is also the
source of the founding titan's power
from controlling other titans to
creating wall titans to altering the
bodies of the subjects of ymir all of
the founding titans feats are done by
ymir after she is given the order either
by a scream or in person through the
world where ymir resides however because
yamir was fritz's slave she only listens
to the commands of the royal family thus
only the royal family can use the
founder's power stay tuned we still have
many interesting titans to cover carl
fritz the next one on our list is carl
fritz also known as the king of the
walls he was the 145th king of eldea and
was the one responsible for its downfall
over a century before the main story
began carl fritz was crammed king and
inherited the power of the founding
titan for many hundreds of years various
families subservient to the fritz family
were constantly at war with each other
for control over the eight titans a
civil war which carl fritz was ashamed
of rather than following the method of
his ancestors and using the founding
titan to maintain order in the nation of
eldia kingfritz conspired with the tiber
family keepers of the warhammer titan
fritz and the tibers fabricated the hero
of marley whose name was helos while the
world was led to believe that hilo
started the aldian civil war king fritz
moved the capital of elder to paradise
island while war raged on the mainland
kingfritz used the power of the founding
titans to place countless colossal
titans in the construction of three
walls maria rose and china around the
last remaining territory of veldia in
which the subjects of emir could finally
live in true peace with the people of el
dia gathered within the walls carl fritz
used his power again to alter the
memories of all the subjects of emir
erasing all knowledge about the world
outside of the walls in order to protect
the royal family king fritz renamed the
royal family to the reese family who
would live in hiding as nobles while a
different bloodline would take the fritz
name as found in titan carl fritz had
many abilities as we already mentioned
his most powerful ability was creating
an endless army of colossal titans that
could destroy the entire world beyond
the walls but apart from his power to
create titans he was also able to pass
down his memories to an unknown member
of the rhys family after death however
they and all their heirs also inherited
his belief that a world ruled by titans
would be true peace this influence is so
strong that even people that wanted to
stop the titans changed their minds when
they received the power deciding not to
make a move and refusing to reveal the
reason even to their own families yuri
reese yuri was the younger brother of
rodris as their father was the inheritor
of the founding titan yuri and rod
pleaded with him to free humanity from
their tyranny but he always refused to
do so or wouldn't explain why he
wouldn't some time later yuri
volunteered to be the next founding
titan with the full intention to use it
to stop the titans however after he
inherited the power of the titans and to
memories of the world from their father
rod could tell by his eyes that he had
inherited that same ideology just like
his father and all other kings before
them yuri refused to stop the titans and
tell everyone the lost memories of
mankind some time later kenny ackerman
discovered that yuri was the true king
tracked him down and tried to kill him
however he was stopped by yuri who
caught him with his titan's hand kenny
did not give up after this even throwing
a knife at yuri and pointing his gun at
him however even after this yuri spared
his life yuri with the knife still stuck
in his arm bowed before kenny and
apologized because of the prosecution of
his family and his frustrated attempt to
create a paradise within the walls this
heavily surprised kenny who wondered how
a powerful being like him could bow
before someone like himself from that
point on kenny was not only his
bodyguard but also a close friend and
jerry ceased the attacks on the
ackermann bloodline because of his royal
blood yuri had the full abilities of the
founding titan and could manipulate the
memories of the subjects of yamir rod
calls this the invincible power frida
reese frieda reese was rodrice's eldest
daughter and historia's half-sister she
was the true queen of the walls and she
inherited her power from previously
mentioned yuri she was present with the
reese family the night grishieker raided
the reece chapel she listened as grisha
pleaded with the rhys family to protect
them against the titan invasion
following the fall of walmaria for a
moment frida appears willing to agree to
grisha's request but then she seems to
be forced to change her mind due to the
first king's will she then argues with
grisha from the first king's position
stating that humanity within the wall
must perish to protect mankind beyond
them she attempts to deter grishav by
stating that even if he takes the
founder from her he can't wield its
power already aware of this grisha
shares with frida his own titan's
ability to see its future inheritor's
memories he tells frida that in the
future set out for them he will eat the
founder and end the royal bloodline but
hesitates due to his reservations in
killing children frida's family urges
her to kill grisha while he is
vulnerable however grisha resolves to
transform before this is possible frieda
transforms into the founding type and
battles grisha's attack titan she was
eventually defeated by grisha and eaten
by him thus gaining her powers and
memories grisha then proceeded to
slaughter her mother and siblings with
only her father escaping the massacre
grisha yeager for the longest time
grisha was a mysterious character to all
of us in the early seasons we knew
nothing about him but after learning
about his past we finally understood how
important he was for the entire aod
story as an eldian living in marley he
followed his father's footsteps and
became a doctor he lived in the liberio
internment zone and later joined eldin
restorationists after being betrayed by
his own son he was sent to paradise
island along with his wife to be turned
into pure titans fortunately for him he
was saved by the owl the secret leader
of eldian restorationists the owl chose
him as the successor of the attack titan
and entrusted him with the mission to
save the eldian empire by going into the
walls and stealing the founding titan
grisham spent years inside the walls
working as a doctor treating the noble
families ends looking for information
about the royal family he even started
his own family and had a son named aaron
who he named after the owl after years
of searching he finally found the reese
chapel and faced the royal family not
long after he killed frida and obtained
the founding titan even though he
possessed the founding titan he couldn't
use its abilities as he didn't have
royal blood we never saw him in his
founding titan form as he passed it on
to aaron right after but since he had no
royal blood he would probably look the
same in his founding titan form as he
did in his attack titan form aaron
jaeger with the power of the founding
titan the grisha stole from the reese
family aaron possessed the founding
titan abilities but was unable to use
them the first time that aaron managed
to use the founder's power was
completely by accident he touched the
palm of dina fritz's titan causing all
the nearby titans to attack and devour
her and setting the same titans upon
bertolt and reiner by possessing the
powers of the founding titan aaron made
himself a target for the whole country
of marley their main goal being to
capture him alive it was a while later
when he met yamir the founder for the
first time that he was able to access
the full powers of the founding titan he
convinced ymir to lend him her power and
with the new abilities he inherited he
released all the colossal titans that
were inside the walls starting the
so-called rumbling by fully utilizing
the powers of the founder he was able to
telepathically communicate with all of
the subjects of ymir declaring war
against the whole world aaron's founding
titan was drastically different than
yamir fritz's founding titan or any
other titan that we've seen so far his
founding titan form was absolutely
massive he was without a doubt the
biggest titan that ever existed it
looked like it was made completely out
of bones it was one giant ribcage with
no flesh the only part of his titan that
had flesh is his head although it was
significantly deformed inside the titan
aaron's head was disconnected from his
torso having been decapitated and
rejoined by yamir's power he moved with
the help of his rib cage that was spread
all the way to the ground it was fast
enough to keep with the marching
colossal titans one of the most
important and unique abilities that
aaron possessed and that we haven't seen
so far in the show was summon it he was
able to summon all previous titan users
in their titan forms brainwashing them
into fighting against surveycore and
marley on his behalf during chapters 135
to 138 we could see many past titan
shifters like bertolt porco grisha and
even tom xavier additionally we could
also see a lot of titan shifters that
were never shown in the show before it's
safe to say that besides the amir aaron
was the strongest titan in the entire
story with the ability to destroy the
entire world if he wanted to but instead
he chose not to giving humanity a chance
to fight back click on this video where
we explain all the things you missed in
attack on titan go on click it